If you haven't heard of Project 2025,
it is a project written by a large group of Republicans
that is to be handed to the next Republican candidate
so that he can implement it into his presidency.
Basically, it is a plan for the next term
if the next candidate is a Republican.
If you haven't heard of Project 2025,
it is very scary.
I'm 19 years old,
I'm biologically female,
and I'm a member of the LGBT community.
I can hide the fact that I'm gay,
but I can't hide the fact that I was born a woman.
And women are one of the targets of 2025.
If 2025 is past,
Republicans are seeking to
completely ban abortion altogether,
no matter the circumstances.
Project 2025 also seeks to
rewrite the definition of marriage,
which includes getting rid of gay marriage.
Project 2025 plans to ban
all gender affirming healthcare.
Please don't let a bunch of rich white men
whose rights have never been questioned since
the beginning of our country
dictate our future.